are you like rotted out live welcome to
another hangout super excited to have
Jen back with me the fantasy copywriter
Jen how you doing hey good how are you
good we've been updating series a little
bit since we talked last I kind of
helping jen grow her business as a
copywriter and heard one word is fantasy
and well what's a quick update first we
were getting to like the topics what's
what's the quick update on what you've
been doing your youtube channel your
business what's been going on yeah so um
with my youtube channel I've been
continuing to do at least a video week
I've been trying to do at least one
personal at least little bit of personal
reflection as well as as well as a
copywriting seems to cooperating video
per week I've been pretty successful at
that I've been for sure I've been at
least one video a week it's just I
haven't done always too um and and
that's going really great it's going
really grand really have without I've
been doing some work on my website
because I decided it was time to start
building up my list and Bill of an
audience I can send emails to and
updates to and so um I'm excited about
that because I created a freebie and I
created that and put it on my website
and I'm working on another one and a
video that's corresponding to that too
so I'm really excited about that I've
been able to really focus my business
warrants that's been awesome I love it
and you know what the kind of ties into
it that question already came in from
Brittany she said she's he's an abstract
artist trying to remind people to dream
do you have suggestions on how i can
reach my target audience besides post
into my wall on facebook and going to
art fairs so she wants people to dream
and she's connecting people through her
art what do you think on getting people
to kind of find her and reaching her
audience oh that's a good question well
I think all kind of social media I mean
obviously you want to do this social
media that you love and it makes sense
to you right and so whether that's
Facebook or Twitter which I've personal
on Twitter and YouTube those from those
two of my favorites but there's also
Instagram which would be awesome for you
because you have this visual medium and
putting that on Instagram I think would
be awesome and then doing things to help
load your list so having some kind of
give away some kind of freebie that
helps encourage people to dream and then
you can start spreading your message
that way to sew and the other
think I might try eventually as myself
personally as Facebook Ads I haven't
done that yet but I've heard that's
really great way to get people to know
what you're doing and what you're up to
knit doesn't even have to be a Facebook
ad for something you're selling it could
be like for a free beer giving away or
if you have a blog post for you or
posting your artwork I don't know what
you're doing exactly with your art but
that's not a great way to get more
exposure to those things yeah i love the
suggestions just quick them facebook ads
facebook guys work really well when you
can really define who you're going after
if you want you know single moms in
Nebraska who like Justin Bieber and play
volleyball you know you can find out
totally the more specific you know who
your target market is then then it makes
sense to run Facebook God otherwise and
I would also try to make sure you know
what your business model is you have
something to sell because you're gonna
start spending money and I hate spending
money before I make you money I love the
Instagram idea I think if you're in a
visual medium what I would try to do is
tie it in the pop culture somehow I
would look every day at what the most
popular Twitter hashtags were I'm what's
trending on Instagram and then something
that's happening the news and inject
some dream on top of it and some of them
might be controversial so you might take
something that's negative and turn it
into something positive I would love
like so example you know Donald Trump
goes off and says something crazy again
how could you turn that into a positive
art piece that makes people want to
dream ah that's a good idea yeah you can
do it i mean so an example a great
attack would have been the women's day
that just passed uh you know if you if
you have a i don't know exactly what
kind of art you choose knowing but if
you have some famous women that you look
up to a new respect and what their
dreams were maybe over their heads or
like little bubbles at showcase what do
dreams were um and that's the positive
example the more artistic one is in
thinking okay well how can I like the
creative one how would I turn out
something super negative into something
positive through dreaming
because I think that really that can
really take off because there's so much
negativity and people want the positive
message I'd love to see you being able
to do that uh whatever to with the whole
like you know like my thing is to help
people fantasize right so it's similar
thing even not a business model I'm
still trying to encourage people to
write down their fantasies because it
you know words make a real and so I
really think it's a bigger message that
i have and i tried spread that and my
social media too and so one thing you
could do to is you could I don't know if
you're a writer but you could do some
you know blog post that you don't even
have to be super long but still are able
to show off your artwork and encourage
people to dream in some way shape or
form too because that's what's helped me
to use get my my facebook page actually
has been exposure I think through my
youtube and a blog post that done guest
blog posting on other people's sites
they've seen me and then they like my
facebook page so this about don't
they're too cool so what I wanted to go
over with Jen today was a little work in
progress a little live action a lot of
the things that Jen is great at is
coming up with the right words to use in
the right environment so if you want to
do a sales page she'll she'll talk about
how to read the right headline in the
sub headline in the description and call
the action and all that stuff and if you
watch your YouTube channel she's got
tons of suggestions and feedback on that
and as I was setting up this call I was
looking at how we called these things
and thought this is pretty not this
again it'd be better so we've called
this coaching call with and I always
include the twitter handle of whoever
i'm talking to so people can find them
you know so this as much as Jen so you
can find her on Twitter the fantasy
copywriter episode number 12 and if you
like that name could be way better and I
thought I'd be a good exercise to go
through live and also for everybody
watching to think about okay how can i
how come my titles you better if it's a
youtube video if it's a sales letter if
it's a newsletter or the subject line
you know it's the most important thing I
mean once they watch the video they can
get into the content but the title is so
important I thought we need something
better so yeah let's create
and I can we make the title of this
session more tied into people's fantasy
yeah well one of the things I like to do
tues I personally I start out with word
bubbles and think about words that are
kind of related to what we're doing so
fantasy and coaching and a call right so
I'm thinking like it's sorta like a
session so it can be like a fantasy set
sesh or I like to use alliteration so
fantasy focus fantasy you know fabulous
fancy focusing or something like that um
and you know I think it'd be you know I
also think about coaching and it's kind
of like a teaching it's like a class
right so um you know get schooled with
Evan the fantasy cooperator I don't know
these are just because some things that
came to my mind when Evan brought this
up did you have a thought that I'm in no
and his for people-watching there was no
prep time on this it's just like hey and
if this is cool to do so it's all like
live brainstorming action but I think
it'd be helpful to kind of understand
the thought process that you go through
this is what what happened with your
clients or when you're sitting down to
make a video or create content um so so
the audience is you know entrepreneurs
they're coming to learn through your
story to see what you're going through
and then kind of take that to then you
know improve their business whether it's
just staying motivated to see somebody
who's hustling and trying to build their
business and understand that I'm not
alone or whether it's a tactical what
strategy that they can go and actually
implement into their business um so
that's kind of like the point of the
series and building it around your one
word of fantasy and helping other
entrepreneurs try to apply that to what
they're doing to uh that's the goal of
the series so how do we reflect that in
how would you reflect that in the title
what would we go yeah I would probably
think to about like what you know some
things you just said like strategy and
helping other entrepreneurs to write so
I would probably create some more
bubbles off of that you know you could
even use this sort of you know if you
were to do a similar session with
somebody else you know like somebody
else is one word like if they're one
word was shine you know maybe it's like
a strategy session or strata
strategy sesh with Evan you know the
famous II strategy session or the shine
strategy sesh ah what else would I you
know I don't know I would think about
some of the words that you use to Evan
because you know this is if you wanted
to continue this series with other
people with one word um in the words
like ze obviously believe you're right
yeah um I think it would be how old the
habit as something that could be applied
to other words as well so that people
are trying to figure out there one word
I like the shine kind of shadow to Rishi
there uh so that people can see okay
well here's how one person is doing and
here's how somebody else is doing it and
just given them a different perspective
but the theme is the same whether it's a
series like we've done 12 now so whether
that's a series or if it's just a
one-off um it'd be good to have it be
able to be mixed between different
people needed yeah so many legs do
something off a belief like um I don't
know believe school with Evan believe I
mean I was thinking to like you know
like if it was like if we were on blab
because I know we've done these on
google and on blab you could do a
believe lab yeah um huh i like i like
using the word like i like using your
word in there so then that can be
swapped out if we're doing it with yeah
that's somebody else but then the rest
of it like if its strategy sash or if
it's something else that that's a
consistent kind of theme and the
difference is the whatever the one word
that we inject in yeah I like strategy
sesh um this is what I usually pull out
my thesaurus to and he'll talk about
things you know so um let's see and I
like this little alliteration what do
you what are you putting this or so
people cooler following along what are
you put into the source now you're
looking up strategy or session or what
do you put it in I'm looking obsession
exactly um and it just has meaning
gathering um and I'll see any exciting
words get together jam session jam I
like that jamming
a POC Jam a shine jammer rise jam but i
like i like strategy sesh right now i'm
talking to strategy um game plan uh-huh
yeah there's nothing exciting there yeah
and so why why so exciting you've
mentioned a couple times so you're yeah
that's good like just how down the
process entrepreneurs you know they're
going to the office or they have a title
that they may not like they go to the
source they're now trying to find other
words to mix in to have greater meaning
but it's not just the meaning of what
we're doing it's now you're also like
one of your criteria has to be exciting
yeah exactly well something that's very
catchy for me and I also the thing I
like to do is not just think about so
Anna look at if award on thesaurus I'm
not just looking for another word to use
I'm looking for something that will like
kind of like help my brain think about
another word so it's another just
another tool to brainstorm so you know
for example you know let's just take I'm
going to randomly take it anymore my
credit card right if your dick credit
card you can think about things that
relate a credit card that are like you
know not not necessarily on the Susilo
Soros but like you know MasterCard and
then you think about visa and you think
about what does visa do I don't just
random things that are not related
specifically to that word to the exact
meaning but it will make you you know
it'll be interested in catchy to use so
um and you like to think about the
purpose like you said strategy like
we're trying to come up with good
strategies for entrepreneurs so what are
you trying to do and what else makes you
think about strategy for entrepreneurs
right I don't know that's gonna help how
I do it no I'm like okay so so far we
have hashtag fantasy strategy sesh and
then the two other elements that we have
historically at least put in is
featuring well here I said with this as
much normally I would do like ft dots of
featuring the twitter handle and that's
that's one because I want people to also
learn
you and show off your name I'm because
if I just put Jennifer jen or Jennifer
price people have super common names too
so that it may not always find that
person and also a lot of people will end
up tweeting these videos and when they
tweet it your name will get pulled up so
you'll get you'll get recognition and
you'll know that somebody's tweeted your
video so you can you can respond to and
I want people to build connections
beyond me right just I want you to
connect with the audience to and get
things happening not always have to have
me as the middleman so that was one I
maybe you know maybe we don't need it
but I'm curious you have your thoughts
and then the second part was the episode
number that this is part of the series
some people may have a number some
people just maybe a one-off thing so if
we start with hashtag fantasy strategy
sash what about those other two
components in the Twitter and the
episode number i like that i like the
twitter and episode number yeah I think
that's good to include that way it
clarifies who it's with like you said
the hubster audience look look up who
you're talking to so like if you were
doing one with rishi you know a shine
started you sesh with you know a tree
she kept TV episode number one or
whatever right so do you like do you
like with do you like ft do you like in
brackets but he thinking ah I like ft ft
period okay ah I like in brackets maybe
because the emphasis is on the
strategist ashtray and on their one word
um and then the episode number two right
otherwise you're gonna have the same yes
look for us would be the same thing
every time we didn't have
differentiation on the numbers yeah so
when you do that though but I guess it
does make sense right what I have been
in the past is I put in brackets EP
period well this one is called brackets
EP period 12 yeah I like that yeah I
like in brackets Oh posh tag fantasy
strategy sesh ft period at this as much
in brackets
EP period 12 that's a long I were like
you know what i'm gonna i'm going to
paste it in because it's hard to visual
i'm going to paste it into our chad you
guys can't see our chat but I just
pasted in there to kind of see what it
looked like because I know it's hard to
just hear it and not see it at least for
me I'm very visual person can you see it
in the chat there I can't see the shower
like I like the alliteration a strategy
sesh um I mean what else you do Evan on
these calls with people besides helping
with in with strategy like what else
would buy how you might how might you
describe it um I think so it's a
combination of the the strategy which I
would try lump in you know the actual
ideas on what to do like I need to go do
this unique like we were talking to
Britni you need to go on Instagram and
create these dream pictures and post it
around a common themes that are
happening right now in the world right
so like here's here's a step that you
need to take the other half of it is the
motivation is just the yeah like the
getting the energization the don't do it
right inspiration motivation energy
power to actually take action on what we
talked about so those two things kind of
make up what I try to accomplish on
every call that I do but especially the
these sessions so this captures this
captures a chunk of it for sure yeah
yeah like it i like the inspiration part
two um and the action hmm I if I had to
pick one I would go with the strategy /
I wouldn't want to call it like
inspiration session cuz it's not just
it's not just inspiration right um yeah
I agree I want like meaningful results
to come out of every time I have a
conversation with somebody so um yeah I
like to do I mean you can
just use your one word thing to instead
of strategy like obviously I wouldn't
alliteration there with sesh but like
fantasy one word one word collab or one
word something yeah I'm saying because I
like you know if you do this other
people who had a one word that would be
great a great way to do it you know I'm
saying yeah um so what I am yeah what
I'm thinking as a lot of people don't
know about the one word and the meow
part of the education process so if if
anything I think it might be it might be
a replacement to the fantasy where it's
hashtag one word strategy sash okay
featuring this is much but then we're
not putting in your one word or if we
are then it's longer right and this is
an important question to where
entrepreneurs are trying to fit stuff
into a headline and they want to cram as
much in but then as you make it you know
what when is too long right what do you
belong in the headline yeah it's hard
because yeah I mean I think obviously
just the faintest escape strategy sash
it's really the main headline and then
it's featuring you won't even be able to
put a featuring ads at this is much in
the parentheses too so it's really the
headline is fantasy strategy sesh and
then featuring this is my jeppesen 12c
I'm saying yeah paste that in so there
you go this sort of looks like that yeah
exactly I like that the episode it could
be a number sign if you want to get rid
of epo though we're using a hash tag at
the fantasy so yeah ah that's a good
question I think either ways fine I
think you can use number I think I Do's
number cuz I think it will know it's
different than hashtag right number 12
well shortens it shortens our character
space oh there you go that's what it is
now hashtag fantasy strategy sesh open
brackets featuring this as much number
12 close brackets
huh you're liking that I like that I do
yeah what about you I'm working it okay
now talk through is what this is
important i think so we're taking out
session and you shorten it to sash
what's the thinking behind that why
would you do that why should
entrepreneurs you know some people I
think why it's not even a word sash why
session set a session well I think
because it helps make it a little bit
more catchy and it is sort of a kind of
slaying you know word people use a lot
when they're talking about session so
it's not like it's not recognized but
even if it weren't and you can also you
can invent words I mean you can invent
words that you know help help your brand
to UM know if Evan was like I don't like
that word it doesn't make sense for me
didn't but that word then that be don't
tell a different story because it has to
reflect on your brand to oven but um you
know I like it cuz I think it's a little
more catchy yeah i don't i don't use the
word sash but i also not against it i
think in my mind it session might be
really formal yeah and sashes informal
and these are not I whoa they're not
they're not either then I'm like super
formal but they're also did not like
crazy and fro I'm not in the bath robe
or something but it hey it's uh they
were not the conference room all
buttoned up and doing a full
presentation with slides and stuff right
well I'm like you know you sit in the
starbucks right it's not it's not you
know I got my Tim Hortons here no but no
I mean I like it's just you know so I
think a lesson for entrepreneurs and
they're trying to crap their headlines
and think about the design may like a
word but it doesn't you like the meaning
behind it but it's a little too
something's little too formal is little
too strict you can make up a new word or
abbreviate it and even though it's kind
of it may not be in that Oxford
Dictionary it may still capture the
essence of what you want in a much
better way and so kind of be flexible
with the language i think is the lesson
for I mean you just did it naturally
like oh yeah I have fantasies that
strategy sessions great but for I think
a lot of people they mean you
there's a lot of steps to kind of walk
through and so I think that that's
helpful to understand the way you think
of making those things happen great
point great point and it is important
you just made another really great point
which is it should really reflect what
what it is you're doing to you know I
love it anyway um sean is writing in to
say how do you know if something is
you're a hundred percent passion so you
love you know writing how do you bother
you how did you know that that was your
passion uh well for me I knew it's my
passion because I could do it all the
time 24 7 and I never got a sick of it
um I love writing and like when I really
realized how much I love writing it was
like like it hit me you know like I
don't mind doing it at ten o'clock at
night and I'm this is my favorite TV
show because I'm writing um so for me it
was something that I just could do over
and over and over and not get sick of
and be challenged by and be inspired by
at all at the same time yeah Sean I was
Shawn who I said um yeah I mean I echo
what Jen said I think you need to find
something that you just fall in love
with that you can get lost in that you
can when you look up at the clock like
what that much time went by that you
can't go to sleep because you're
thinking about it and that's not every
night you know like I'm not up every
night until 14 yeah exactly there's
there's that too but but it's something
that it just makes you come alive you
know like talking entrepreneurs helping
entrepreneurs for me it gives me energy
right I can forget to go to the bathroom
and forget to eat and forget to sleep
and be jetlagged in whatever and then
meet an entrepreneur and I'm just it
just it makes me excited I hope that
comes through in the stuff that I create
and so I think it's one of the things
that you just you feel in your heart and
it's not something that you think about
if you have to think do I love this then
you don't love this you know then you
got to go do something else it's the
thing that you can get lost in and often
times it doesn't make sense you know
like salsa dancing for me didn't make
sense because I'm too tall I didn't
learn salsa growing up all of these
things were against me it's a huge
optimo speak Spanish you'd understand
their music but I went into a salsa
class I just loved it and that's it and
now that I own this awesome school you
know uh and so if you have to think
about it I feel like it's not the right
thing and if you don't know what you
want to do it's super common explorer
just try a bunch of stuff out until you
find the thing that makes you come alive
and you love it I agree yeah
experiencing is good and writing down
just do some free writing about things
that you love just what things that
you'd love to do in your spare time or
that you even want to try or things that
you would do I know use this before to
Evan things you would actually do if
even if you couldn't didn't get paid for
it like things you would do on the side
this just because you loved doing it you
know I was another day Ford eventually
Isabella's writing in to say I let my
son listen to your videos and it
inspires him so much he's a 16 year old
music artist named Virgo start thank you
he's on his way to the top you're
appreciated what what would what advice
would you give to either 16 year old
musician or organs mother who cares
about him I wants to support him on his
journey uh what kind of advice would you
give Wow um well to the mom I mean just
the fact that you wrote in wanting to
support is awesome I mean cuz I think
it's so important to have people around
you who believe in you who wants you to
succeed and will help you and don't
squash your dreams I mean that's just
huge so I'm just like proud of you as a
mom go mom alright that's awesome um and
I gosh this is a really great question i
think just doing things to get yourself
out there and sharing your your love of
music with other people I mean give
value to other people in other ways too
whatever you can do to share your music
with other people and give it exposure
yeah I think about my upbringing and
believe comes to my parents and my
parents are not entrepreneurs and they
you know couldn't really give me any
kind of advice growing up or even now
about how to be an entrepreneur and what
to do but they always supported me
anything I did they recognized it they
thought it was great they took me I was
selling baseball cards
as my one of my first businesses and
they would take me to baseball card
shows and we'd go to Florida during
spring training and get autographs from
the baseball players and you know they
didn't understand how you could sell a
piece of cardboard for a hundred dollars
you know didn't make any sense of that
but it was their sons passion and so
they were invested into helping me be
successful and I think the greatest
thing you can give your son is is cough
can feel like what he's doing is
important is he's going to have down
days he's gonna have days when he thinks
I can't be a singer you know my things
aren't taking off I can't get a deal
nobody wants to listen to my music all
this stuff and just having you say hey
you know I love your music it's great
and reminding of the good things he's
doing and encourage him to do more and
you know maybe you set up your garage so
he can practice with his band or
whatever maybe there are some events
that he can play at that you're on the
volunteer committee for or something but
it's much more than a mental and
emotional side than the you know I need
to give him the exact strategy to be
successful it's I think it's
underestimated how important the people
around you are and for entrepreneurs you
know for yours for you guys watching to
having a network of people who believe
in what you're doing and trying to make
you the best version of yourself and
love what you're all about is important
because if you just surround it by this
this t-shirt triumph over the little man
you know the little man of the haters
right ah if you're surrounded by the
little man in your life then you're
never going to go and do something great
and build a great company I agree and
one other little note I'd like to add to
is that like I know it's hard sometimes
when you really love somebody and you
really want them to succeed and you have
you have a lot of your own ideas that
you might like suggest to him and they
might not resonate with him they may be
like oh I don't think that's a good idea
and that's okay like don't don't stop
supporting just because they don't like
your ideas cuz they're gonna have their
own path I think the important thing is
just to support them and and believe and
believe in them and and and you know
just just that they know that you
believe that they can make it and that's
all they need now that someone is
mentioned that your link that i put p to
your channel description wasn't working
so to make sure it's video so much right
returns it yeah some video so much yeah
you know in the description it got cut
off so i just fixed that so thank you
brittany for letting us know about that
you can check it out i appreciate it
yeah so you can go check out video so
much it's now working in description um
awesome well i mean half an hour flies
pretty quickly yeah awesome I like the
new name we've got it
already I've already updated it so now
people are watching this it's already
going to be on the hashtag fantasy
strategy sash featuring this is much
number 12 I love it me too I dig it I'm
glad you like it cool and then for
everybody watching go check Jen's
youtube channel out there saying there's
still not working you might have to
refresh the stream after because the
description got updated and it won't
load unless you refresh the page but
yeah check out Jen new videos two videos
every week yeah and it's all about one
having more fantasy in your life but
then also how to create copy and text
that will help your business be
successful with creating landing pages
or YouTube videos or websites or
whatever exactly how to figure out what
your customer your clients fantasies are
so you can use those in your marketing
messages yep love it well thank you jen
p your time appreciate you stopping by a
local starbucks fame came to the
strategy stash and learned it evan it
was always fun as always nice for
watching and we'll see you soon you can
buy